perte de vue pour cette réunion au
collège bienvenue martel l'inspectrice
d'académie est venu annoncer où seraient
répartis les élèves à la rentrée
prochaine pour raisons de sécurité
l'établissement est en partie fermé et
de gros travaux sont nécessaires mais
les professeurs refusent la nouvelle
organisation nous avons dit qu'il était
prêt mais que c'était prématuré en
quelque sorte on met un peu la charrue
avant les deux donc on pense que c'est
pas une bonne idée
on pense que il faut que les gens se
rendent compte que c'est le département
qui aura la responsabilité du maintien
et des travaux ou alors de la fermeture
leur crainte que le département ne
décide de fermer définitivement
bienvenue martin depuis la chute d'une
fenêtre en décembre dernier l'un des
bâtiments du collège est interdite
depuis une grosse partie et 380 élèves
est scolarisé dans cet autre
établissement de la ville où une
situation jugée difficile et pénalisante
pour les enfants comme pour leurs
parents ici en réunion avec les
professeurs tous veulent rester à
bienvenue et que des préfabriqués
provisoire il soit installé sa eu un
impact très négatif sur les enfants
psychologique aussi pédagogique encore
parce que les enfants et avec ce père ce
bouleversement cette perturbation et
savent pas où donner la tête la crainte
c'est de avec nos enfants soient
dispatchés dans d'autres collèges et ça
permet ça ne permet pas de donner une
bonne éducation à nos enfants
si on voulait dispatcher à droite à
gauche c'est pas la solution mais ces
serres pour sécuriser le collège les
travaux prendront trois ou quatre ans et
pourrait coûter plusieurs millions
d'euros le département doit décider le
mois prochain s'il engage ou non ces
travaux